حسنًا ، لا يزال يتعين عرض هذا على
البرلمان البريطاني قبل أن يصبح قانونًا ،
ولكن بمجرد تمريره ليصبح قانونًا ، وليس هناك من
توقع أنه لن يكون هناك شخص
يدعم حماس قد يواجه عقوبة تصل إلى 14 عامًا في
السجن ، وهذا سيكون أقصى
عقوبة للتنظيم أو  المساعدة في
جمع التبرعات لحماس أو حتى
التلويح بعلم حماس باتت جميلة
وزيرة الداخلية قائلة إن هذه
المنظمة معادية للسامية بشدة معاداة السامية
، كانت هذه
كلماتها وقالت إن هذا من شأنه أن يساعد في
جعل المجتمع اليهودي في المملكة المتحدة
يشعر بالأمان.  قالت إن
المنظمة لديها وصول واسع النطاق
ومتطور إلى الأسلحة
لتدريب الإرهابيين
، وقالت إنها منظمة إرهابية ، لذا من
المرجح أن يأتي التصويت أو على الأقل أمام
البرلمان من المرجح أن يأتي الأسبوع المقبل ،
ولم تأت أي أصوات سياسية مهمة
بعد إعلان باتيل الجميل.
إلى الأمام حتى الآن
لإثارة المخاوف ولكن بلا شك
سيكون هناك سياسيون لديهم بعض
المخاوف بشأن هذه الخطوة  لكن لكن بشكل
قاطع إعادة المملكة المتحدة
لتتماشى مع الاتحاد الأوروبي
الذي تركته قبل عامين فقط ،
نيك روبرتسون ، CNN london